it has been 22 years since players first
got to experience the virtual lands of
the forgotten realms
in the original boulder's gate so while
there are plenty of folk out there
excited for the upcoming baldur's gate 3
they may not have played through
bioware's 1998 rpg gem
in this video we're going to do a quick
recap of the main story beats of both
boulder's gate 1 and bowlers gate 2.
i say quick you can see how long the
video is just in case you want to study
up before baldur's gate 3's early access
comes on october 6th
the sword coast provides the backdrop
for the first adventure in the baldur's
gate series
with baldur's gate itself being the
largest and most populated city in the
region
it's important to keep the world of
faerun the sword coast and boulders gate
in mind
as players will be revisiting the world
in its new form come the release of
baldur's gate
3. the main story revolves around the
in-world factions such as the flaming
fist and black talons
but mostly focuses on the main player
character searching
for their own ancestry in history all
the while thwarting a mysterious armored
figure whatever character
you create the story origins are the
same being raised in the fortress
library of candle keeps south of
baldur's gate with your friend and first
companion immoen
and the adopted father figure of your
story the mage gorion
at this point in the story you learn
that strange things are afoot in the
realm
with iron production mysteriously
halting metal crumbling is accursed by
magic
and nerd wells scouring the land taking
iron and metals as their treasure
the walls of the fortress monastery are
no longer safe as bandits make an
attempt on the player's life
upon leaving candle keep with gorion you
are ambushed by bandits led by the dark
armoured figure from the opening cut
scene
somewhat gruesomely grind defeats most
of the enemies but dies doing so
as the player character flees and
reunites with imoen your first companion
in the campaign
it's me emilyn this starts the first
proper chapter of the game
and as the player makes their way east
they may encounter and recruit monteron
the halfling fighter and tsar the mad
human necromancer
arriving the friendly arm inn you meet a
mage called tarnish who quickly casts
mirror image and attacks you
on your party despite the name of the
tavern it's
seemingly not that friendly inside
however you will find two more potential
companions
khalid the stammering half elf fighter
and his wife the half elf druid
jahira regardless of who you choose to
accompany you in the story of baldur's
gate
you venture south toward the town of
nashkel its carnival and the mines
while danger is still looming over the
player and another attempt on the life
will be made the most important part of
visiting this town
is that you have the potential of
recruiting one of the best companions
in the boulder's gate series stand and
deliver that my hamster might have a
better look at you
i am of course talking about the
neurotic berserker ranger minsk
and his miniature space hamster boo you
can however also meet volo in the town's
tavern a character that we have also
seen appear during some of the boulder's
gate 3 pre-release gameplay sessions
a returning character of any sort gives
me a glimmer of hope to anyone keeping
their fingers crossed when it comes to
being reunited with old companions
it is the kobold filled mines that will
be the next waypoint through the
player's story
the chapter culminating in a battle
against moulihae an evil cleric
summoning hordes of kobolds and
skeletons defeating him and taking his
holy seal will begin chapter 3 as you
make your way to beragost and volunteer
yourself to sort out the local bandit
problem with the potential of
infiltrating the camp with the subtle
ruse of offering to join them
either way the chapter will come to a
close as you fight the bandits
raymond vent hacked and britic taking
their letters and making your way to
chapter four
the journey then takes you through
cloakwood back towards some of the dark
and dank minds in the pursuit
of answers to the iron crisis after
battling your way through guards as well
as dressers and his adventurers
you may start the process of flooding
the mines although hopefully not before
recruiting the charming dwarf
yes lake before you escape however the
player's party must face off against
battle horrors and the teleporting mage
daveyon
only after they are defeated do you
retrieve the river plug
and complete this chapter it is here
where you will be able to finally make
your way into the city of boulder's gate
first meeting scar second in command of
the flaming fist the mercenary company
tasked with keeping peace and upholding
law
to the northern half of the sword coast
i serve the flaming fist
you will also meet duke eltan one of the
four dukes of the city and leader
of the flaming fist is he who will task
you with investigating the iron throne
a shady merchant organization that is
known for assassinations and having
contracts with enemy states you discover
that this organization's leaders are in
fact
back in candle keep the previous library
fortress that you once called a home
agreeing to head there and pursue your
leads will have duke eltan teleport you
back to candle keep and begin
chapter six as you gain access back to
the keep and explore your once familiar
surroundings it appears things are not
quite what they once were
explorations find a previously unread
letter from the player character written
by your guardian gorian although finding
this will also lead to the player's
arrest
then being found guilty for a murder
regardless of charisma checks and
evidence
and forcing you to be teleported to the
lower catacombs that are teeming with
the doppelgangers
that now control the keep all of this
has been orchestrated by saravak the
armoured figure that killed gorion in
the prologue
and is now inhabiting candle keep with
the rulers of the iron throne
disguised as coravas i can't believe i
didn't realize until
writing this that caravas is just
sarivock backwards how did i not
see that playing the game originally
under candle keep you will also
seemingly be reunited with gorian
but is in fact doppelgangers taking his
form
through facing the twisted forms of old
friends as well as enemy basilisks
eventually the player character is able
to escape from candle keep and return to
boulder's gate in chapter seven
however boulder's gate is now in the
grip of the new head of the flaming fist
the corrupt angelo dosan working for
ceravok
facing arrests and hostilities the
player is framed for crimes against
boulder's gate
and you must find the evidence needed to
clear your name and in return the city
to peace
either avoiding the flaming fist or
killing them
through your investigation you find that
the situation has been orchestrated
by the same armoured figure saravach it
is throughout your searches that you
find out that saravach is in fact
your half-brother with machinations of
godhood both he and the player character
are barles-born
mortal children that are born from the
lord of murder baal
to prolong his life baal would have his
children sacrificed by priests
in a bloody ritual in an effort to
circumvent the prophecy of his death
this ritual however was thoughted by
gorian and a group of harpers
an organization dedicated to maintaining
the balance between
good and evil while gorian took the
player character in and raised them
sarawak was left to wander the streets
alone until he was taken in by the iron
throne leader
his plan was to use the iron throne and
the sword coast bandits to drive
boulder's gate and arm to war
thus starting murder and bloodshed on a
massive scale
and using that power of death to ascend
up to his own godhood
and assume the new mantle as lord of
murder upon confronting sarawak you'll
be thrown into what is likely the
hardest battle you've yet to face
me face the new lord of
murder but as you beat him you will see
the essence of barr being snatched from
him
as it is pulled back into its domain and
thus ends the original story of baldur's
gate
although the siege of dragonspear dlc
that came with the enhanced edition of
baldur's gate continues
the story that ended in 1998.
the expansion starts with you clearing
out the remains of saravac's followers
but in the weeks that followed
saravock's demise all of your followers
apart from immo and have left
and there are rumors that the player
character did not defeat sarawak for the
good of the land
but so they could in fact take his place
but now as the rest of his forces are
being mopped up the story shifts focus
to a crusade
called by a warrior named khalar argent
also known as the shining lady
being sent north by a contingent of
flaming fist soldiers alongside warnings
the shining lady is making her way down
the sword coast and is threatening the
city
the mercenaries have orders to stop
their advance at the castle of
dragonspear
one of the early battles that take place
between the coalition from boulder's
gate and kailar's forces
occurs along the river where baal the
player's father had been killed by
cyric the mad prince of lies many many
years earlier
after the battle the player will suffer
a vision of baal's death
and burns the symbol of the god of
murder into the stone of the bridge
something that understandably the
surrounding soldiers don't
take too kindly to the party must then
sneak into dragonspear castle
to gain intel about the shining lady
although instead discovers one of her
lieutenants her fenan
speaking to an unknown source after some
skirmishes and an assault on the
coalition camp
your party and allied soldiers attack
dragon spear castle
trapping kayla and the keep as her chief
lieutenant hernan casts a paralysis
spell
over the whole castle this conjuration
however trapped both allied and enemy
forces alike revealing her flan's true
plans of travelling into the nine hells
and unleashing his master onto the
material plane as the spell dissipates
kayla and the player ventured through a
portal
into the hellish dimension in pursuit of
their new common enemy
before her fenan can unleash the demon
bellapet this section takes place in the
first layer of nine hells
avernus a location that we know we will
be returning to in boulder's gate 3
after its announcement during larian's
panel from hell after the defeat of the
demon and summoner alike the shining
lady reveals that her true intentions
was to free her
uncle from the nine hells and that the
crusade was in an effort to revive him
as penance for blood spilled kayla
remains in the nine hells to guard the
portal
the player returns to the mortal plane
to celebrate another victory but that
knight is wrecked by nightmares and
visions of being attacked by an avatar
of ball
twisted from the form of ski silver
shield as you defend yourself in a
terrorized state
you're waking from the dream however to
find ski silver shield dead
stabbed seemingly by your hand and with
clerics being unable to revive her as
her soul is trapped in the dagger the
killed her
you are slapped in irons and dragged
back into baldur's gate to answer for
your apparent crimes
the discovery that you are set up by the
hooded man comes to you as the figure
himself
visits in an effort to twist the player
into obeying their murderous bloodline
as you escape into the woods however you
are reunited with immoen
although unfortunately ambushed and
starting the story
of baldur's gate 2 shadow of arm
your eyes burn as a thin accurate mist
rises from the ground and envelops you
your mind clouds shadow figures strike
and fade away
your companions cries echo in your skull
and the world around you fades to grave
at the start of baldur's gate 2 shadows
of arm you awaken in the dungeon of the
elven mage perennicus
the main antagonist of baldur's gate 2
as he performs some
less than savoury experiments on you the
being currently
probing and prodding you with steel and
magic was in fact
the hooded man from the siege of
dragonspear completing the link between
games a side note is that in the
original release of the game orenicus
was of the human race
but was intended to be an elf this small
blip was fixed in the enhanced edition
of the game that was released many years
later
it is a familiar face that saves you
from the bonds of captivity
as your first companion of the previous
game becomes your first companion of
this one
emon unlocks your cage and you move
forward and rescue other familiar faces
unlocking jahira's cage and goading
minsk with the loss of his beloved diner
here
into using his berserker rage to burst
his open
oh oh
you are a smart one i understand now
while making your way past genies
goblins and dryads jahira will learn of
the death of her husband
another previous potential companion
colleague throughout your exploration
companion imam would start to utter some
peculiar dialogue
hinting that things may not be as they
seem upon leaving the catacombs you come
face to face with orenicus
as he utterly tears his enemies apart
with magic emoin casts magic missiles of
her own
and for their use of unsanctioned magic
in the city of athcatler
they are both apprehended by the cowled
wizards as you journey through the slums
of ap katla you meet galen bale
who will know how to rescue immoen but
needs a whopping 20
000 gold pieces in order to share that
information chapter 2 starts with bales
starting you on the quest
to earn that impressive pile of gold and
chapter 2 also contains one of the most
important decisions in shadows of
arm once you've gone to the 15 000 gold
mark for completing quests
raiding enemies and setting items you
will be approached by a mysterious woman
named valen
urging you to meet her mistress bodhi in
the graveyard district
you will also be offered a similar
message by galen reducing that 20k to 15
if you choose to meet him instead these
two paths will lead you into a decision
you must take at the culmination of
chapter 2.
go to the graveyard and meet bodie and
choose the side of the vampires
and attack the shadow thieves or give
the money to galen and take down the
vampires instead
each party will offer you help to rescue
immoen and only through making this
choice can you progress the main story
attacking the vampire guild will lead
you to the docks and graveyard districts
finding guild effects and killing them
for their involvement with the vampire
guild
you'll learn of their contact in the
athcatla graveyard which leads you to
the vampire lair
there you are faced with spiders traps
golems and more deadly encounters until
you find the coffins of the sleeping
vampires and drive stakes through the
hearts of the hibernating beasts however
killing the three vampires gala durst
and lassal will summon bodhi
she is an extremely difficult enemy as
only blunt weapons will work against her
but once you have wounded her
sufficiently she will flee with that
quest complete the shadow thieves guild
will hold up to their end of the bargain
and grant you passage to the island
where imwin and arenicus are being held
by the cowl wizards
in chapter 4 there'll be some changes to
the quests and events depending on your
allegiance
if you side with the thieves for example
the ship captain will betray you
and summon vampires to attack your party
as you make your way through the island
and to spell hold
erenicus will make himself known to you
as one of the cowled wizards
and if yoshimo is still in your party
from the start of the game he will also
reveal himself to be working
with the evil elven mage at the climax
of boulder's gate you learn that you are
a child of baal
the god of murder but it turns out that
like yourself
emilyn is actually one of baal's
children also and aranika's goal is to
drain that power from you
through of course a magical ritual
through which you will enter into a
dream
in this dream you will face a demon who
will permanently reduce one of your
stats by one
very rude and you are only able to
defeat it by finding imogen in this
realm between realms
and facing baal together i have drained
you
drained you of the very thing that made
you special
it is the worst of curses i should know
through this ritual erenicus has stolen
your divine spirit and has ordered the
vampire body to kill you
you are able to escape through the
labyrinthine corridors of spell hold
and are faced with a choice as how you
leave the island either via portal or by
ship regardless of your choice however
you will end up
in the underdark the underdark is a
network of many
huge caverns throughout the world of
faerun and bolt's gate
and inhabited by some of the most
dangerous entities in the realms
it's a space we've seen teased for
baldur's gate 3 but here as you escape
the island of spell hold you get to see
the first
virtual glimpse of the bizarre landscape
and creatures that call the place home
with a silver dragon adalon transforming
your party into drow to allow you
entrance
through their gates and tasking with
finding her lost dragon eggs stolen by
herrenicus
through the city you'll be facing
enemies and allies that you will again
recognize if you've been keeping up to
date with the baldur's gate 3 news
both mind flayers and githyanki can be
found through the deepest darkest areas
of the city
while mind flayers are not the main
enemies in the game as they appear to be
in boulder's gate 3
they are still an extremely dangerous
insidious brain infecting race
the main goal here is to recover the
aforementioned dragon eggs
and doing so will teleport you from the
underdark city of usnatha
to the surface alongside adalon and
right into the middle
of your next large battle at the start
of chapter 6.
so now back in the real world the next
step is to try to recover your soul
and immunes from bodhi anarenicus
surrounded by elves you must prove your
allegiance and disdain for the evil mage
who you now hunt to commander elhan
doing so will secure your passage back
to the city of atkatla
where your adventure first started and
eventually to the graveyard where you
may have first met the vampire cabal who
you now pursue
finally defeating the vampire bodhi and
driving a wooden stake through her heart
will allow emilyn to reclaim her soul
and venture on forward to the elven city
of sildenessela once in the city you
will be advised to speak to the elven
queen elzamie
you'll be presented with the talisman of
rifline an elven god of protection and
guardian of harmony and be tasked with
recovering powerful elven artifacts and
symbols to allow you passage to the tree
of life
erenicus and his minions are found to be
sapping the energy from the elven world
tree
with parasites killing these will summon
aranacus now that he has been cut off
from the tree's energy
upon delivering the final killing blow
to the antagonist that has plagued you
since you escaped the clutches back at
the start of the game his soul
will be dragged down to the nine hells
however you and your party die with him
and your souls will too be taken down
into the abyss
it seems that your fate is not sealed
within these hells however as you were
given the option of opening the abyssal
door back to the material realm
by offering up five tiers of ball earned
by completing the challenges set in hell
your actions in these trials may change
the alignment of your character with
them potentially falling to evil
which means in the story of the game
giving into the dark influence of the
lord of murder you will in fact
encounter the wraith form of the
antagonist of baldur's gay 1
sarivoch representing wrath as well as
the other demons of greed
selfishness fear and pride securing a
tear from each demon grants you a boon
depending on how you acquired it for
example in the trial of pride sparing
the dragon will grant 20
resistance to all elemental damage but
killing it will give your character 20
000 experience
regardless of your choices you made good
or evil the five tiers will lead into
the final battle against the damned
erenicus and his demons
the toughest encounter of the game and a
fight for your very soul
delivering the final blow will see your
soul return back to you
as you continue to live as baal spawn
this is however not the end of the
prophecy with the story of your party
continuing into the expansion
the throne of baal after the battle in
hell you awaken to find yourself
in a sacred grove of ancient gods after
being refused access to the elven city
because of your bile spawn bloodline
this plane will be the start of the
final unfolding of the prophecy
that has followed your character since
the beginning of the very first game
this pocket plane contains other barrel
spawn that are all trying to kill each
other
and also you in an attempt to ascend to
the throne of the lord of murder this
area also contains the soul of saravach
your bile spawn half brother and the
antagonist of the first boulder's gate
game
who is now available as a companion and
advisor if you agreed to give him part
of your soul
leaving this pocket playing the journey
continues in the city of saradoush
where you will meet melasan and the
leader of the town gromnir il khan
who mistakes you for invaders and will
immediately attack
when you finally confront romney and
defeat them melisandre shares with you
that the other bass bomb besieging the
city is in fact
invincible and urges you to find a way
to make them vulnerable to death again
something accomplished by finding his
disembodied heart in the marching
mountains
continuing this path and defeating the
five legendary bass bomb will bring you
back to the pocket plane
where seemingly your task is complete
although the truth of the matter is that
melasan who has been helping the
dismantling of all the bars born
is in fact emelisan mastermind of the
five and the high priestess of baal
himself who was taxed with resurrecting
the god of murder but not only does she
betray you she also betrays her deceased
god
as she desires to take the throne and
ascend to godhood herself
this is easily the toughest fight of the
saga so far
against a powerful mage and a cleric who
summons abyssal monsters to fight
alongside her as she saps the energy
needed for her evil godly ascent
during the final attacks when you're
about to finish your story and she is
near death
the celestial solar beings appear to
grant victory to you
your final choice is to either release
all of the taint of bile that you have
absorbed during your fights with their
spawn
and allow the solar to remove all
essence of the god of murder from the
world
or absorb what is left and become a god
yourself
whatever you decide the ending will be
influenced by your choices
and the good and evil alignment that
follows through the game and as your
party makes their final comments on your
actions the final act
of baldur's gate 2 comes to a close and
that ghouls and goblins is a brief
overview of the main story arcs of
baldur's gate 1 and 2
as well as their expansion packs now
expansion packs are what we had before
dlc was a thing for you youngans out
there
next week we will be covering everything
else you need to know before the
baldur's gate 3 release
with much more content on the way
leading up to the game and of course
across its launch and early access
development so to be sure you don't miss
any of that
make sure you subscribe to gamespot
[Music]